OKAY. ALL RIGHT. WE WILL BEGIN
OUR SENATE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS COMMITTEE HEARING
IN 30S.
ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING TO BEGIN
OUR HEARING FOR TODAY,
WEDNESDAY, JUNE 19TH, FOR THE
SENATE BANKING AND FINANCIAL
INSTITUTIONS. HEARING. WE DO NOT
HAVE A QUORUM, BUT WE DO HAVE 12
BILLS ON TODAY'S AGENDA. AND SO
WE ARE GOING TO BEGIN AS A
SUBGROUP, BEFORE UNTIL WE GET A
QUORUM. SO WE DO HAVE SOME
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS HERE. WE'RE
ACTUALLY GOING TO BEGIN, WITH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO ON AB
2424. YOU MAY BEGIN WHEN YOU ARE
READY. THE MIC. IT WAS WORKING.
HEY. OKAY THANK YOU SO, SO MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. AND MEMBERS REALLY
APPRECIATE THE OPPORTUNITY TO
PRESENT AB 2424. FIRST, I'D LIKE
TO THANK THE CONSULTANT FOR THE
THOUGHTFUL ANALYSIS TO AND TO
INDICATE THE ACCEPTANCE OF THIS
SUGGESTED CLARIFYING AMENDMENTS.
AS THE ANALYSIS POINTS OUT,
CALIFORNIA'S EXISTING
FORECLOSURE PROCESS IS, IN TOO
MANY INSTANCES, GROSSLY UNFAIR.
WHEN A MORTGAGOR CAN'T PAY BACK
THEIR MORTGAGE LOAN, THE LENDER
IS ALLOWED TO SELL THE PROPERTY
AT AUCTION, AND THE LENDER TAKES
BACK THE LOAN'S REMAINING
BALANCE AND THE HOMEOWNER
RECEIVES SURPLUS FUNDS. IF THERE
ARE ANY. UNDER THIS PROCESS, THE
HOMEOWNER OFTEN LOSES TENS OR
EVEN HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS OF
DOLLARS OF ACCRUED HOME EQUITY
BECAUSE OF THE AUCTION PROCESS.
ON THE OTHER SIDE OF THE LEDGER,
WEALTHIER CORPORATE SOMETIMES
ALL CASH INVESTORS BENEFIT FROM
THESE UNFAIR BELOW MARKET SALES
BY ACQUIRING PROPERTIES AT
BARGAIN RATES. FORECLOSED HOME
OWNERS ARE OFTEN LOW INCOME,
ELDERLY, IMMIGRANT OR DISABLED,
FREQUENTLY, THE HOME IS THEIR
ONLY ASSET AND THE HOME EQUITY
IS THEIR LIFETIME SAVINGS. THE
CUMULATIVE EFFECT OF TAKING
BILLIONS OF DOLLARS OUT OF HOME
EQUITY FROM THESE CONSUMERS PUTS
ONCE HOUSING STABLE BUT LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES AT RISK OF
HOMELESSNESS AND INHIBITS
ECONOMIC MOBILITY. AB 2424 WILL
REQUIRE FORECLOSING LENDERS TO
POSTPONE A FORECLOSURE SALE IF
THE HOMEOWNER PROVIDES THE
LENDER WITH A LISTING AGREEMENT
FOR THE SALE OF THE PROPERTY.
THIS WOULD ALLOW THE HOMEOWNER
THE OPPORTUNITY TO MAXIMIZE THE
SALE VALUE OF THE PROPERTY WHILE
STILL ENSURING THAT THE LENDER
IS MADE WHOLE. IT WOULD ALSO SET
A MINIMUM BID REQUIREMENT ON THE
FIRST ATTEMPTED FORECLOSURE
AUCTION, SO THAT THE SECURED
PROPERTY COULD NOT BE SOLD BELOW
THE THRESHOLD. CALCULATE AT 75%
OF THE PROPERTY'S MARKET VALUE.
THIS PROCESS WOULD ALLOW THE
HOMEOWNER THE OPPORTUNITY TO
RECOVER MORE OF THEIR EQUITY
THROUGH THE FORECLOSURE SALE
PROCESS, RETAINING ACCUMULATED
WEALTH IN CALIFORNIA'S MOST
VULNERABLE FAMILIES AND
COMMUNITIES. AB 2424 DOESN'T
SEEK TO PREVENT THE MORTGAGE
HOLDER FROM GETTING REPAID. IT
ONLY SEEKS TO BALANCE THE
EQUITIES SO THAT BOTH THE BANK
AND THE OWNER OF THE PROPERTY
GET A FAIR SHARE OF THEIR
INTEREST IN THE VALUE OF THE
HOME HERE, WITH ME TODAY IS
ROBERT HARRELL AND CECIL VOSSLER
OF THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA TO TESTIFY AS WELL.
GREAT. THANK YOU. AND BEFORE WE
ALLOW YOU TO BEGIN, WE'RE GOING
TO GO AHEAD AND ESTABLISH QUORUM
. SENATOR LIMÓN HERE, LIMÓN
HERE. NILO HERE. NILO HERE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. HERE
CABALLERO. MINH. NGUYEN.
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO HERE.
GREAT. THANK YOU. AND NOW WE
WILL BEGIN, GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS. ROBERT
HARRELL, EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE'RE THE SPONSORS
OF THIS MEASURE. LIKE TO THANK,
THE AUTHOR, THIS JOURNEY AND THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS DOES A REALLY
GOOD JOB OF SUMMARIZING WHAT
WE'RE TRYING TO ACCOMPLISH HERE
AND HOW IT DOES THIS. THIS
JOURNEY BEGAN A FEW YEARS AGO
WITH A BILL BY SENATOR
ARCHULETA, THAT LED TO A COUPLE
YEARS OF ON AND OFF
CONVERSATIONS ABOUT HOW COULD WE
HELP PEOPLE, SO THAT THEY DON'T
EITHER DON'T GET FORECLOSED ON
OR IF WORST CASE SCENARIO THEY
DO, THEY'RE AT LEAST ABLE TO
RECOVER SOME OF THE EQUITY
GAINS. THERE ARE SOME HORRIFYING
CASES I'LL LEAVE THAT TO THE
OTHER WITNESS TO TALK A LITTLE
BIT ABOUT WHAT THEY'VE SEEN IN
THE MARKETPLACE, BUT WE
APPRECIATE THE GOOD FAITH OF ALL
THE STAKEHOLDERS AND HOW THIS
HAS BEEN WORKED OUT, WE THINK
IT'S A VERY REASONABLE,
RESPONSIBLE MEASURE, AND WE URGE
AN EFFORT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
HI. MY NAME IS SAL VOSSLER. I'M
THE FOUNDER AND PRINCIPAL OF THE
VOSSLER LAW FIRM IN OAKLAND, AND
I EXCLUSIVELY HANDLE CASES
RELATED TO PREDATORY LENDING AND
WRONGFUL FORECLOSURE. MANY OF MY
CLIENTS, PAST AND PRESENT, HAVE
LOST THEIR HOME IN FORECLOSURE.
ONE OF MY CLIENTS HAD HER
$800,000 HOME SOLD FOR ONLY
$50,000 AT AUCTION. AT 77 YEARS
OLD, AS A RETIRED IMMIGRANT
WIDOW WITH A DEPENDENT ADULT
DAUGHTER, SHE LOST $750,000 OF
HOME EQUITY. ANOTHER CLIENT, AT
86 WITH COGNITIVE DECLINE, HAD
HER OAKLAND PROPERTIES, A
PRIMARY RESIDENCE AND A RENTAL
PROPERTY SOLD FOR A COMBINED
$205,000. THEY WERE WORTH $1.5
MILLION. IT'S PROFOUNDLY UNFAIR
THAT SOMEBODY CAN DO THE RIGHT
THING FOR SO MANY YEARS BUY A
HOME, MAKE THEIR PAYMENTS FOR
DECADES, SAVE EQUITY FOR
RETIREMENT, AND HAVE ALL THAT
EQUITY STRIPPED FROM THEM. AT
THE MOMENT THEY LOSE THEIR HOME
THE MOMENT THEY NEED THAT EQUITY
THE MOST. THIS BILL IS THE
PRODUCT OF OUR GOOD FAITH
NEGOTIATIONS WITH THE INDUSTRY
STAKEHOLDERS, AND I URGE AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU ALL
RIGHT. NOW, WE WILL INVITE ANY
WITNESSES IN THE ROOM IN SUPPORT
TO PLEASE COME FORWARD. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, DAVID SHAPIRO,
CALIFORNIA SCHOOL EMPLOYEES
ASSOCIATION, IN SUPPORT OF THE
BILL. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON.
ANNA BUCK, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS AND SUPPORT. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU, THANK YOU. NOW, ARE
THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? PLEASE COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. SEE NO PRIMARY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
GENERAL? ALL RIGHT. CNN WILL
TAKE IT BACK TO THE COMMITTEE
MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS. VICE CHAIR NILO, I'M
CURIOUS ABOUT THE TESTIMONY OF
THE WITNESS RELATIVE TO ACTUAL
CASES. THOSE ARE BOTH SO
DRAMATIC. I'D HAVE TO BELIEVE
THAT SOMEWHERE IN THERE, THERE'S
COLLUSION. EITHER A PURPOSEFUL
ATTEMPT TO LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
BIDDERS OR COLLUSION BETWEEN THE
BIDDERS AND THE SELLERS, I'VE
SEEN THAT BEFORE, ACTUALLY, THAT
THE SECOND CASE I TALKED ABOUT,
THE 86 YEAR OLD CLIENT, THE
BUYER OF, WELL, THE LENDER TOOK
THE PROPERTIES IN A IN A CREDIT
BID AND THEN SEVEN DAYS LATER
SOLD IT TO A CONVICTED BID
RIGGER. SO, YEAH, I THINK IN
THAT CASE, DID THE, HOMEOWNER
RECEIVE SOME REDRESS VIA LEGAL
ACTION, WE HAVE REVERSED THE
FORECLOSURE AND RECOVERED THOSE
PROPERTIES. GOOD DEAL. THANK YOU
. ANY OTHER QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS? IS THERE A MOTION? SO
MOVED. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, I
JUST THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST AN AYE
VOTE. GREAT. SO WE DO HAVE A
MOTION BY VICE CHAIR NILO, AND
WE WILL GO AHEAD, AND, CALL THE
ROLL. THIS BILL. SORRY. THIS
BILL HAS A THE HAS A
RECOMMENDATION OF Dð PASS. BUT
FIRST AMEND, AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ASSEMBLY BILL
2424, MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR LIMÓN I LIMÓN I NILO I
NILO I BRADFORD. CABALLERO. MINH
NGUYEN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I.
ALL RIGHT, ALL RIGHT. YOU WANT
ME TO CALL HER? WHY DON'T WE
CALL THE ROLL AGAIN? SINCE TWO
MEMBERS JUST WALKED IN? OKAY
ASSEMBLY BILL 2424, MOTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I MINH.
MINH I GOT FIVE GREAT. THAT HAS
FIVE VOTES. WE'RE GOING TO WE'RE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND, LEAVE
THAT ROLL OPEN. SO NOW WE WILL
AS WE GET OUR NEXT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER, I'M GOING TO GO AHEAD
AND DO THE CONSENT AGENDA. WE
HAVE FOUR BILLS ON CONSENT ON
THE CONSENT CALENDAR ITEMS
NUMBER TWO AB 2618, ITEM NUMBER
FOUR AB 2637, ITEM NUMBER SEVEN,
AB 2062 AND ITEM NUMBER EIGHT AB
2422. DO WE HAVE A MOTION FOR
THE CONSENT CALENDAR? SENATOR
MINH MAKES THE MOTION. CAN WE
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL? SENATOR
LIMÓN. AYE. LIMÓN AYE. NILO.
AYE. NILO AYE. BRADFORD
CABALLERO. CABALLERO. AYE. MIN.
MIN AYE. NGUYEN. PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO. AYE GREAT. THANK
YOU. THAT HAS FIVE VOTES. NEXT
WE WILL HAVE ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN, COME FORWARD. YOU HAVE A
COUPLE BILLS, BUT WE'LL START
WITH, ASSEMBLY BILL 2618. IF
THAT WORKS FOR YOU. THANK YOU.
GOOD SEEING YOU AGAIN. AGAIN, I
WANT TO THANK, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT AB 2618 UNTIL JANUARY
1ST, 2026. GOVERNMENT CODE
SECTION 53601.8 ALLOWS BUT DOES
NOT MANDATE A LOCAL AGENCY TO
DEPOSIT UP TO 50% OF THEIR
OVERALL SURPLUS FUNDS WITH A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION THAT USES
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS AS A MEAN OF
COLLATERALIZATION. USING
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS ALLOWS THE
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION TO ACCEPT
DEPOSIT FROM A LOCAL AGENCY,
EXCEEDING THE FEDERAL DEPOSIT
INSURANCE CORPORATION OR
NATIONAL CREDIT UNION
ASSOCIATION STANDARD INSURANCE
LIMIT OF $250,000, WHILE
MAINTAINING FULL INSURANCE
COVERAGE OVER THE ENTIRETY OF
THE LOCAL AGENCY'S DEPOSIT
UNLESS EXTENDED. ON JANUARY 1ST,
2026, THE MAXIMUM 50% OF LOCAL
AGENCY FUNDS THAT MAY BE PLACED
UNDER RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS WILL
REDUCE TO 30. DEPOSITORY
INSTITUTIONS THAT USE RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS IS A MEAN OF TO
COLLATERALIZE AGAINST LOCAL
AGENCY DEPOSITS OR COMMUNITY
BANKS. CREDIT UNIONS OPERATING
WITHIN THE GEOGRAPHICAL REGION
OF THE LOCAL AGENCY. THIS
MEASURE MAINTAINS FLEXIBILITY
FOR LOCAL AGENCIES AND BANKS AS
THEY WORK TOGETHER IN MANAGING
LOCAL AGENCY FUNDS AND IN
SERVING THEIR COMMUNITIES.
AB2618 WILL EXTEND THE JANUARY
1ST, 2026 SUNSET DATE TO JANUARY
1ST, 2031, THEREBY EXTENDING
CURRENT LAW AND THE PERMISSIVE
ABILITY FOR LOCAL AGENCIES TO
DEPOSIT UP TO 50% OF THEIR
OVERALL SURPLUS FUNDS WITH A
DEPOSITORY INSTITUTION THAT USES
RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS IS A MEAN OF
COLLATERALIZED THÀNH. THIS BILL
WILL ALSO REQUIRE THE CALIFORNIA
DEBT AND INVESTMENT ADVISORY
COMMISSION TO SUBMIT A REPORT TO
THE APPROPRIATE POLICY
COMMITTEES OF THE LEGISLATURE ON
THE DEPOSIT OF SURPLUS FUNDS
PURSUANT TO THE SECTION BY LOCAL
AGENCIES HERE. TO TESTIFY, WE
HAVE ROB WILSON, A
REPRESENTATIVE, CALIFORNIA
CREDIT UNION LEAGUE. ALSO, JASON
LANE, REPRESENTING THE
CALIFORNIA BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR. MEMBERS
OF THE COMMITTEE, JASON LANE
WITH CALIFORNIA BANKERS
ASSOCIATION, THANKS FOR THE
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK ABOUT THIS
IMPORTANT GOOD GOVERNANCE
MEASURE. THE BILL MERELY REMOVES
A SUNSET DATE THAT HAS BEEN IN
EXISTENCE, I THINK, SINCE, WELL,
THE LAST BILL TO INCREASE THE
PERCENTAGE OF SURPLUS FUNDS AT A
LOCAL AGENCY CAN INVEST FROM 30
TO 50% WAS IN 2019. FORTUNATELY,
THE STATUTE SUNSETS IN NECK WELL
2026, AND SO THIS BILL WOULD
REMOVE THE SUNSET DATE, THE
THEORY BEHIND RECIPROCAL
DEPOSITS IS ALLOWS LOCAL
AGENCIES TO INVEST THEIR SURPLUS
FUNDS IN A COMMUNITY BANK OR
CREDIT UNION IN THEIR LOCAL
JURISDICTION. AND THE THEORY IS,
IS THAT THOSE FUNDS THEN WOULD
BE DISTRIBUTED OUT INTO THE
COMMUNITY THROUGH LOANS. IT ALSO
ENSURES THAT THE LOCAL AGENCY
CAN CAN HAVE QUICK ACCESS TO
THOSE FUNDS IN THE EVENT OF A
LIQUIDITY CRISIS, WHICH IS NOT
ALWAYS THE CASE WITH OTHER
INVESTMENT VEHICLES. CURRENTLY
UNFORTUNATELY, THERE ARE LOCAL
AGENCIES WHO ARE BUMPING UP
AGAINST THE 50% THRESHOLD AND
RIGHT NOW, WITH INTEREST RATES
BEING SO HIGH, UNFORTUNATELY
THEY ARE GIVEN THE GUIDANCE,
UNABLE TO INVEST ANY FURTHER
THAN THE 50, IN THEIR LOCAL BANK
AND CREDIT UNION, WHICH IS
UNFORTUNATE BECAUSE BANK
ACCOUNTS RIGHT NOW ARE YIELDING
HIGH RETURNS AS OPPOSED TO SOME
OTHER INVESTMENT VEHICLES THAT
THAT THAT THAT THE LOCAL AGENCY
WOULD BE FORCED INTO THE, THERE
WERE UNFORTUNATE AMENDMENTS THAT
WERE ADDED TO THE BILL IN LOCAL
GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE THAT
REQUIRE A FAIRLY EXPENSIVE AND
ONEROUS REPORT BY THE STATE
TREASURER'S OFFICE, WHICH WE
THINK IS UNNECESSARY AND
BURDENSOME AND COSTLY. THE
RECIPROCAL DEPOSIT PRODUCTS HAVE
BEEN AROUND FOR 20 YEARS. EVERY
DOLLAR THAT THE LOCAL AGENCY
INVESTS IS FDIC INSURED. THERE
HAVE BEEN, FDIC RESOLUTION BANKS
THAT HAVE FACED RESOLUTION AND
LIQUIDATION. AND IN ALL
INSTANCES, DEPOSITORS HAVE BEEN
MADE 100% WHOLE, WITH THE FDIC
INSURANCE. SO WE HOPE THAT THE
SENATE WILL RECONSIDER THOSE
AMENDMENTS THAT WERE ADDED IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT COMMITTEE AS AN
ADDITIONAL BURDEN THAT JUST JUST
DOESN'T NEED TO HAPPEN. SO THANK
YOU FOR AND WE ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR. ROBERT WILSON
CALIFORNIA CREDIT UNION LEAGUE
KEEP MY COMMENTS VERY SHORT.
JUST LIKE TO ECHO MY COLLEAGUE
AT THE BANKERS HAD TO SAY THIS
IS AN IMPORTANT PROGRAM FOR OUR
MEMBER CREDIT UNIONS AND HELP
INVEST IN THE COMMUNITY. I'D
LIKE TO THANK THE AUTHOR AND THE
COMMITTEE FOR THEIR TIME TODAY.
THANK YOU. OKAY. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT OF THE BILL? PLEASE COME
FORWARD. ALL RIGHT. SEEING NO
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, DO WE HAVE
ANY PRIMARY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION? SEEING NONE. WE WILL
TURN IT BACK TO THE MEMBERS. ANY
WE HAVE A MOTION BY, SENATOR
MINH AND A QUESTION FROM VICE
CHAIR NINO. YES. WITH REGARD TO
THE AMENDMENTS, THAT MAKES NO
SENSE. LITERALLY Kò MAKES NO
SENSE, THIS IS A COMMON WAY OF
DEPOSITING FUNDS WITH ONE
INSTITUTION AND HAVING THE FUNDS
DISTRIBUTED TO OTHER
INSTITUTIONS. STOCK BROKERAGE
FIRMS COMMONLY COMMONLY DO THIS.
IT IS EMINENTLY SAFE. HOW CAN WE
GET THOSE AMENDMENTS REVERSED,
WELL, THE NEXT THE NEXT STEP IS
I THINK THIS HAS A REFERRAL TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE, AND IT
IS UP TO THE SENATE TO DECIDE,
YOU KNOW, IF IT WOULD LIKE TO
KEEP THE REPORT IN THE BILL. I
TO US I THE TREASURER HAS TO DO
THE REPORT AND I THINK THERE'S
OVER A THOUSAND LOCAL AGENCIES
THAT WOULD HAVE TO REPORT UP TO
THE TREASURER ON THE UTILIZATION
OF RECIPROCAL DEPOSITS. AND THAT
SEEMS LIKE IT WOULD BE A LENGTHY
AND COSTLY REPORT. IT'S ALMOST
AS IF THE EDUCATION COMMITTEE IS
TRYING TO TORPEDO THE BILL. I IS
THERE ANYTHING WE CAN DO ABOUT
THAT? SO THIS WAS DONE IN LOCAL
GOV, NOT THE EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. AND IT WAS SOMETHING
THAT, OH DID I SAY EDUCATION.
YES I'M SORRY I MEANT LOCAL. SO
IT WAS NOT SOMETHING THAT OUR
COMMITTEE WAS AWARE OF UNTIL WE
RECEIVED THE AMENDMENTS. AND I
DO THINK THAT THE, THE ANALYSIS,
MENTIONS OR QUESTIONS ABOUT
THAT, SO THAT WILL HAVE TO BE
DETERMINED, I THINK ANY CHANGES
THAT ARE MADE, THAT, YOU KNOW,
FROM A COMMITTEE TO COMMITTEE,
DOESN'T MATTER WHAT COMMITTEE IT
IS, HAVE TO BE A BROADER
CONVERSATION BETWEEN THE HOUSE.
SO, BUT THERE IS MENTION OF, OF
THOSE, IN THE, IN THE ANALYSIS,
I'M GOING TO SUPPORT THE BILL,
BUT I WOULD STRONGLY URGE TAKING
THOSE AMENDMENTS OUT OF THE BILL
. IT MAKES ABSOLUTELY NO SENSE.
ONE MORE THING. I WOULD SAY
CALIFORNIA IS AN OUTLIER. NO
OTHER STATE HAS A PERCENTAGE
THRESHOLD. CALIFORNIA IS THE
ONLY ONE THAT HAS A, YOU KNOW,
50% THRESHOLD. SO MEMBERS ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? ALL
RIGHT. WELL THANK YOU. FOR YOUR,
WORK ON THIS, WOULD YOU LIKE TO
CLOSE, SENATOR, PENDING PASSAGE
OUT OF THIS COMMITTEE, YOU HAVE
MY COMMITMENT THAT WE WILL HAVE
FURTHER DISCUSSIONS REGARDING
THE AMENDMENTS WHEN IT GOES TO
THE NEXT COMMITTEE, WHICH IS
APPROPRIATIONS. THANK YOU.
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A VOTE.
GREAT. SO WITH THAT, WE WILL GO
AHEAD AND, WE DO HAVE A MOTION
BY SENATOR MINH, THE MOTION IS
DO PASS AND REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ASSEMBLY BILL 2618. ONE MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR LIMÓN I
LIMÓN I NILO I NILO I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO CABALLERO I MEN, MEN,
I NGUYEN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
HAS FIVE. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
FIVE. WE WILL, GO AHEAD AND PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. THE NEXT BILL
WE HAVE IS ALSO A BILL BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. THAT IS AB
3148. YOU'RE READY TO WE'LL CALL
ANY WITNESSES AND SUPPORT UP,
BUT YOU'RE READY TO BEGIN. THANK
YOU, MADAM CHAIR, FOR ALLOWING
ME TO PRESENT AB 3148. I WANT TO
BEGIN BY THANKING YOUR COMMITTEE
STAFF FOR THEIR WORK ON THIS
BILL. CURRENTLY, PAYDAY LOAN
LENDERS ARE REQUIRED TO PAY
LICENSE FEES BASED ON A NUMBER
OF BRICK AND MORTAR LOCATIONS.
THE LICENSEE OPERATES IN
CALIFORNIA. IN RECENT YEARS, A
NUMBER OF THESE BRICK AND MORTAR
LOCATIONS HAS DECREASED
SIGNIFICANTLY AND ONLINE
TRANSACTIONS HAVE CONTINUED TO
GROW. AT THE SAME TIME,
DEPARTMENT COSTS TO ADMINISTER
THE PAYDAY LOAN PROGRAM HAVE
CONTINUED TO INCREASE BOTH
ONLINE AND IN-STORE.
TRANSACTIONS ARE LEGAL AND
REGULATED BY DPI, BUT BASING
FEES ON THE NUMBER OF LOCATIONS
THEY OPERATE IN THE STATE, NOT
BASED ON THE VOLUME OF
BUSINESSES THEY CONDUCT IN
CALIFORNIA, WHICH HAS LED TO
INEQUITABLE RISE IN COSTS. THIS
BILL WOULD CHANGE THIS PROBLEM
BY REQUIRING THE DPI TO ASSESS
FEES TO PAYDAY LOAN LICENSEES
BASED ON THE VOLUME OF BUSINESS
IN CALIFORNIA, AS OPPOSED TO THE
NUMBER OF LOCATIONS THE LICENSEE
HAS HERE TO TESTIFY. WE HAVE
JOHN MOFFITT ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS, TO PROVIDE ADDITIONAL
BACKGROUND AND ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU MAY HAVE. THANK
YOU. YOU MAY BEGIN. GOOD
AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR. JOHN
MOFFATT, ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL SERVICE
PROVIDERS, THANK THE AUTHOR FOR
CARRYING THE BILL. I THINK IT'S
PRETTY STRAIGHTFORWARD, RIGHT
NOW, DPI HOW THEY ADMINISTER THE
FEES, LICENSING FEES FOR A
NUMBER OF THEIR PROGRAMS. I
BELIEVE THERE'S SIX OTHER
PROGRAMS. IT'S DONE BASED ON THE
VOLUME OF BUSINESS THAT EACH
LICENSEE CONDUCTS IN THE STATE
FOR THE DEFERRED DEPOSIT
TRANSACTION LICENSE FEE. IT'S A
BIT OF AN ANTIQUATED APPROACH.
IT GOES BASED ON NUMBER OF
LOCATIONS IN THE STATE. AND SO
YOU COULD HAVE ONE LICENSEE WHO
HAS ONE STOREFRONT AND DOES
ONLINE LOANS, AND THEY DO FIVE
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS OF LOANS
EVERY YEAR. THEY'RE PAYING
$2,300 FOR THAT ONE LICENSE. AT
THE SAME TIME, YOU COULD HAVE
ANOTHER COMPANY, ANOTHER
LICENSEE WHO HAS TEN STOREFRONTS
AND NO ONLINE PRESENCE OR MAYBE
SOME ONLINE PRESENCE DOING $1
MILLION IN TRANSACTIONS EVERY
YEAR. AND THEY'RE PAYING $23,000
BECAUSE THEY'RE PAYING FOR EACH
ONE OF THOSE TEN LOCATIONS INS,
SO THE PURPOSE OF THIS BILL IS
TO JUST TAKE AND FOLLOW THE
MODEL SET IN THOSE OTHER SIX
LICENSING PROGRAMS AND,
DISTRIBUTE THE, THE, THE FEES
FROM DPI ACROSS ALL LICENSEES
BASED ON THE VOLUME OF
TRANSACTIONS THEY'RE DOING IN
THE STATE ON AN ANNUAL BASIS. WE
ASK FOR YOUR VOTE. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN THE
ROOM IN SUPPORT? PLEASE COME
FORWARD TO STATE YOUR NAME. AND,
AFFILIATION. GOOD AFTERNOON,
MADAM CHAIR ROBERT HERRERA WITH
THE CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA. WE DON'T HAVE AN
OFFICIAL POSITION ON THIS BILL.
I WOULD JUST NOTE THAT, AS YOU
AND SUBSEQUENT COMMITTEES, THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE,
CONTEMPLATE THIS, YOU MAKE SURE
THAT YOU DO NOT EXACERBATE A
FINANCIALLY CHALLENGING
SITUATION THAT DPI IS ALREADY
FACING RIGHT NOW, BECAUSE IF DPI
WINDS UP WITH A REDUCTION IN
REVENUES IN THE FACE OF OTHER
POTENTIAL CHALLENGES THAT
THEY'RE FACING, THAT WOULD
POTENTIALLY LIMIT CONSUMER
PROTECTION EFFORTS BY THE
DEPARTMENT. SO WHETHER THAT'S
NET NEUTRAL OR SOME OTHER
SMARTER WAY TO DO THIS ON A
GOING FORWARD BASIS, WE DON'T
DISAGREE WITH THE PREMISE OF THE
AUTHOR AND THE SPONSOR, BUT YOU
WANT TO MAKE SURE YOU DON'T
EXACERBATE ANY CHALLENGES THAT
ARE HAPPENING AT DPI RIGHT NOW.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT COURT? ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION, WE'LL BRING IT BACK
TO THE MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS?
COMMENTS? ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY VICE CHAIR. I WILL
THANK YOU ALL FOR THAT, AND
CERTAINLY I THINK, YOU KNOW,
WE'LL LOOK AT IT. I THINK WE ALL
CARE A LOT ABOUT DPI. JUST TO
THE COMMENTS THAT HAVE BEEN MADE
AND ARE FOLLOWING WHAT'S
HAPPENING AND THE RESOURCES AND
STAFFING POSITIONS AND
EVERYTHING RELATED TO DPI AS IT
RELATES TO PROTECTING CONSUMER
PROTECTIONS. Ó, IF I MAY, WE
ARE NOT CHANGING THE PART OF THE
STATUTE THAT SAYS THE LICENSEES
HAVE TO PAY THE FULL COST OF DPI
TO, TO ADDRESS THE CONCERN
RAISED. WE'RE NOT CHANGING THAT
PART. WE'RE JUST CHANGING THE
MATH OF HOW THEY HOW THEY SEND
OUT THE BILLS. OKAY. THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR THE CLARIFICATION.
ALL RIGHT. SO WITH THAT, WE DO
HAVE A MOTION BY VICE CHAIR
NHIÀU. AND WE WILL ALLOW YOU TO
CLOSE. I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR A
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. SO WE'LL
GO AHEAD AND MOVE THAT. THAT
BILL HAS A DUE PASS. SORRY A Dð
PASS. AND WE REFER TO THE
COMMITTEE ON APPROPRIATIONS.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3148 MOTION IS
DUE. PASS TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR LIMÓN I
LIMON I NILO I NILO I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I MINH.
MINH I NGUYEN PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO NO, I THAT'S FIVE.
GREAT. THANK YOU SO MUCH. GOOD
TO SEE YOU. GOOD TO SEE YOU.
OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO WE ARE
WAITING ON AUTHORS, SO, YES,
SENATOR PORTANTINO, IF YOU WOULD
BE WILLING TO DO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES. SAWYER. BILL THAT IS ITEM
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN AB 3108.
FILE ITEM NUMBER TEN. SENATOR
PORTANTINO IS PRESENTING FOR
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES SAWYER.
THANK YOU, MADAM CHAIR AND
MEMBERS, OBVIOUSLY PRESENTING ON
BEHALF OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES.
SAWYER, AB 3108, AND I WOULD
LIKE TO START BY REITERATING
COMMENTS FROM THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER WHO EXTENDS HIS THANKS TO
THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR THEIR
WORK ON THIS BILL. HE IS
ACCEPTING THE COMMITTEE
AMENDMENTS. AB 3108 WILL GIVE
VICTIMS A CHANCE TO ACHIEVE
JUSTICE AND REGAIN THEIR HARD
EARNED MONEY BY CLARIFYING THAT
BROKERS WHO DECEIVE AND MISGUIDE
CONSUMERS ARE COMMITTING
MORTGAGE FRAUD. PREDATORY
MORTGAGE LENDERS TARGET
HOMEOWNERS WITH LOW CREDIT
VETERANS, NON-ENGLISH SPEAKERS,
AND THOSE WHO ARE UNBANKED OR
UNDERBANKED. FOR MOST OF THESE
PEOPLE, THEIR ONLY ASSET AND
SOURCE OF EQUITY IS THEIR HOME.
AND WHEN THEY SIGN A PREDATORY
MORTGAGE, THEY RISK LOSING THEIR
PROPERTY. AB 3108 WILL CLARIFY
THAT A LOAN ORIGINATOR WHO
KNOWINGLY CAUSES A BORROWER TO
SIGN A LOAN OR DOCUMENT THAT
CONTAINS MISLEADING STATEMENTS,
IS COMMITTING MORTGAGE FRAUD.
THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOOKS FORWARD
TO WORKING WITH THE SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE TO
CONTINUE, CONTINUE REFINING THE
BILL AND ENSURE IT WILL ACHIEVE
ITS GOALS. WITH ME TO TESTIFY IN
SUPPORT IS ROBERT HARRELL, ON
BEHALF OF THE BILL SPONSOR, THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA AND SILVA, A CONSUMER
ATTORNEY WITH EXPERIENCE IN
PREDATORY LENDING AND WHEN
APPROPRIATE, WOULD RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE. THANK YOU.
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND HAVE YOU,
MADAM CHAIR. THANK YOU. ROBERT.
HAROLD WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA, WE
THANK THE AUTHOR OF THE
PINCH-HITTER TODAY AND ALSO THE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER JONES-SAWYER FOR
THE BILL, THE SCAM THAT WE'VE
BEEN SEEING THE PAST FEW YEARS
THAT IS DEEPLY PROBLEMATIC, IT
TENDS TO TAKE TWO FORMS. THESE
ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE IN SOME
FINANCIAL DURESS. THEY ARE
POTENTIALLY AT RISK OF LOSING
THEIR HOME. THE NOTICE OF
DEFAULT WINDS UP BECOMING KIND
OF LIKE A LEAD GENERATOR FOR
FRAUD AND SCAMS. AND ONE OF THE
SCAMS THAT WE'RE SEEING. AND MR.
VOSLER CAN TALK ABOUT THIS IN A
LITTLE MORE DETAIL, IS KIND OF
SWITCHING OVER ALONE FROM A
RESIDENTIAL LOAN TO EITHER A
COMMERCIAL LOAN, BECAUSE UNDER
COMMERCIAL LOANS, YOU DON'T GET
THE SAME CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
THAT YOU GET UNDER RESIDENTIAL
LOANS. TO OVERSIMPLIFY, OR A
BRIDGE LOAN AND A BRIDGE LOAN IS
USUALLY WHERE THERE'S ANOTHER
PROPERTY BEING PURCHASED
INVOLVED. BUT THAT'S NOT THE
CASE. AND SO MANY OF THE
SITUATIONS THAT WE'RE SEEING ARE
FRAUDULENT IN THEIR INTENT AND
THEIR EXECUTION. AND THE
CONSUMER IS BEING MISLED AND
LIED TO IN THE COURSE OF THAT
TRANSACTION. THAT IS MORTGAGE
FRAUD. THE CHALLENGE IS TWOFOLD.
ONE OAN, BECAUSE ULTIMATELY, IN
THESE CASES, THE CONSUMER IS
SIGNING THE DOCUMENTS. THAT
BECOMES A VERY HIGH WALL TO
CLIMB EITHER FOR PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS WHO ARE NOT TAKING
AS MANY OF THESE CASES AS THEY
SHOULD OR FOR PRIVATE LITIGANTS,
BECAUSE THAT'S SOMETHING THAT,
YOU IMMEDIATELY ENCOUNTER IF YOU
TAKE ONE OF THESE CASES. THIS
HELPS CLARIFY THAT SITUATION.
OBVIOUSLY THERE'S A PORTION OF
THIS THAT'S OVER IN THE PENAL
CODE, WHICH WILL BE DEALING WITH
THE PUBLIC SAFETY COMMITTEE ON.
BUT THAT'S THE HEART OF WHY WHY
WE'RE MOVING FORWARD WITH THIS
APPROACH. AND WE URGE AND I VOTE
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. HI. MY
NAME IS SILVA AGAIN. I'M WITH
THE VOSLER LAW FIRM AND MY FIRM.
MY PRACTICE IS DEVOTED ENTIRELY
TO PREDATORY LENDING AND
FORECLOSURE OF PREDATORY LOANS.
IN 2001, CALIFORNIA ENACTED
LEGISLATION TO COMBAT PREDATORY
LENDING PRACTICES, WHICH
TYPICALLY OCCUR IN THE SUBPRIME
MORTGAGE MARKET. THOSE
PROVISIONS ARE CODIFIED IN
DIVISION 1.7 OF THE FINANCIAL
CODE, AND THEY APPLY TO CONSUMER
LOANS AND NOT COMMERCIAL LOANS.
IN PRACTICE, TO EVADE THE
PROVISIONS OF DIVISION 1.7 AND
COLLECT UNLAWFUL INTEREST FEES,
EVADE LICENSING REQUIREMENTS,
PREDATORY LENDERS AND BROKERS
WILL STEER BORROWERS INTO
SIGNING COMMERCIAL LOAN
DOCUMENTS WHICH ARE UNSUITABLE
FOR THE BORROWERS. THIS INCLUDES
MY 91 YEAR OLD CLIENT ON SOCIAL
SECURITY WHO WAS FRAUDULENTLY
STEERED BY HER BROKER INTO
SIGNING A COMMERCIAL LOAN WHICH
REQUIRED HER TO MAKE A BALLOON
PAYMENT OF $850,000. AFTER ONE
YEAR. MY CLIENT HAD NO
COMMERCIAL INTEREST, SHE LIVED
IN HER PROPERTY. SHE WAS 85
YEARS OLD AND, THE LOAN WAS
GENERATED BY FRAUD. WORSE STILL,
HER BROKER HAD STEERED HER INTO
FOUR SUCH LOANS IN A FOUR YEAR
PERIOD. IN THAT FOUR YEAR
PERIOD, SHE LOST $700,000 OF
HOME EQUITY. AS A RESULT OF
THESE LENDING PRACTICES, SHE WAS
LOSING HER HOME IN FORECLOSURE
WHEN HER DAUGHTER CAME TO ME FOR
HELP. WE'VE HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH MORTGAGE BROKERS AND
LENDERS AND ADVOCATES IN THIS
SPACE, AND YOU KNOW, I THINK
EVERYBODY RECOGNIZES THAT
THERE'S A PROBLEM HERE. OUR GOAL
IS A NARROW ONE. WE WANT TO MAKE
SURE THAT THE LOANS THAT THE
LEGISLATURE HAS ALREADY SAID ARE
PREDATORY. WE WANT TO MAKE SURE
THE BORROWERS OF, OF, OF LOANS,
WHICH ARE GENERATED BY FRAUD,
THAT THOSE BORROWERS ARE STEERED
AND PROTECTED UNDER THE UMBRELLA
OF DIVISION 1.7, EVEN WHEN OR
ESPECIALLY WHEN THEY'RE THE
VICTIMS OF FRAUD, WE URGE OR I
VOTE. THANK YOU. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, PLEASE
JUST STATE YOUR NAME AND
POSITION, BRIAN AUGUSTA, ON
BEHALF OF REYES ECONOMY, THE
NATIONAL HOUSING LAW PROJECT AND
HOUSING AND ECONOMIC RIGHTS
ADVOCATES IN SUPPORT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
SEEING NONE, WE WILL MOVE TO ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION. PLEASE
COME FORWARD. WE CAN MAKE ROOM.
THANK YOU. NOT IN OPPOSITION,
BUT WOULD LIKE TO VOICE SOME
CONCERNS, INDIRA MCDONALD, ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA
MORTGAGE BANKERS ASSOCIATION.
GOOD AFTERNOON, MADAM CHAIR, AND
MEMBERS. WE THANK THE AUTHOR AND
THE STAFF FOR CONTINUED
DISCUSSIONS ON THE AMENDMENT AND
THANK THEM FOR THE AMENDMENT,
NOTED IN THE ANALYSIS. HOWEVER,
OUR CONCERNS REMAIN UNADDRESSED.
RELATED TO THE MORTGAGE FRAUD
CRIMINAL PROVISION OF THE BILL.
DESPITE OUR CONTINUED DIALOG AS
DRAFTED, THE BILL MAKES EXPLICIT
THAT THAT CERTAIN CONDUCT
CONSTITUTES CRIMINAL MORTGAGE
FRAUD. SPECIFICALLY, THE BILL
CALLS OUT LOAN ORIGINATORS
EMPLOYED BY REGULATED LENDING
INSTITUTIONS IF THEY INSTRUCT OR
INTENTIONALLY CAUSE A BORROWER
TO SIGN LOAN DOCUMENTS THAT
CONTAIN A MISSTATEMENT,
MISREPRESENTATION, OR OMISSION,
INCLUDING A DECLARATION OF NON
OWNER OCCUPANCY AND DECLARATION
OF BUSINESS PURPOSE OF THE LOAN
PROCEEDS. EXISTING LAW ALREADY
PROVIDES BROAD APPLICABILITY AND
IMPOSES CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
DELIBERATELY FACILITATING A
MISSTATEMENT, MISREPRESENTATION
OR OMISSION DURING THE MORTGAGE
LENDING PROCESS WITH THE
INTENTION THAT IT BE RELIED ON
BY A MORTGAGE LENDER, BORROWER,
OR ANY OTHER PARTY TO THE
MORTGAGE LENDING PROCESS.
THEREFORE, WE DO NOT BELIEVE IT
IS APPROPRIATE OR NECESSARY TO
CLARIFY THE SCOPE OF EXISTING
LAW WHICH CURRENTLY ALREADY
PROVIDES CRIMINAL PROSECUTION,
TO REMEDY ALL OF THE SPECIFIC
INSTANCES OF FRAUD THIS BILL
TARGETS. FURTHER, WE BELIEVE A
POTENTIAL UNINTENDED CONSEQUENCE
OF THIS BILL WILL BE TO
ENCOURAGE PROSECUTION OF ONE
SPECIFIC TYPE OF MORTGAGE FRAUD
OVER OTHER INSTANCES OF FRAUD
THAT POSE EQUAL OR GREATER RISK
TO THE PUBLIC OR PUBLIC HARM. WE
BELIEVE SUCH DECISIONS SHOULD BE
LEFT TO INDEPENDENT JUDGMENT OF
PUBLIC PROSECUTORS, CALIFORNIA
BANKERS AND MORTGAGE BANKERS
SUPPORTED ENACTMENT OF PENAL
CODE SECTION 532 F AS A TOOL TO
ATTACK FRAUD IN MORTGAGE IN THE
MORTGAGE PROCESS THAT VICTIMIZED
LENDERS, INVESTORS AND
BORROWERS. WE REMAIN SUPPORTIVE
OF ROBUST PROSECUTION IN THIS
AREA, BUT WE BELIEVE SECTION 532
F ALREADY PROVIDES A MEANS TO
ATTACK THE CONDUCT THAT THIS
BILL SEEKS TO ADDRESS. FOR THESE
REASONS, WE CONTINUE TO
RECOMMEND NARROWING THE BILL TO
THE PROVISIONS IN SECTION ONE
AND PROPOSED TO THAT PROPOSED TO
MAKE CRIMINAL LIABILITY FOR
MORTGAGE FRAUD UNDER CURRENT
LAW, A VIOLATION OF THE COVERED
LOAN LAW, THANK YOU. AND WE WILL
LOOK FORWARD TO CONTINUING
DISCUSSIONS AS THE BILL MOVES
FORWARD WITH THE STAFF AND WITH
THE AUTHORS. GREAT. THANK YOU SO
MUCH, SORRY. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION OR WITH CONCERNS
THAT WOULD LIKE TO COME FORWARD.
ALL RIGHT. MEMBERS, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
UNDERSTANDING THAT THE GOOD
SENATOR FROM, SOCAL IS JUST HERE
PRESENTING THE BILL. YES.
SENATOR CABALLERO. WELL, YOU YOU
DREW THE SHORT STRAW TODAY. I, I
HAD, MR. I SAW THAT ON MY NOTES,
SAID QUESTIONS AND SO MAYBE I
JUST GO TO THE EXPERTS IF IT'S
OKAY WITH YOU. SENATOR I GUESS I
NEED TO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATION ABOUT WHAT YOU'RE
SEEING, BECAUSE I HAD MY FIRST
REACTION WAS, THIS IS ALREADY
THE LAW. AND THEN MY SECOND
REACTION IS, WHAT ARE WHAT ARE
WE COVERING? THAT'S NOT ALREADY
COVERED BY THE LAW? AND I GUESS
THAT THAT'S REALLY THE CRUX OF
MY OF MY CONCERN IS, IS, IS I
FULLY SUPPORT, YOU KNOW, WHAT?
WHAT IS HAPPENING IS OUTRAGEOUS.
AND WE NEED TO STOP IT, AND BUT
THE QUESTION IS, HOW DO WE DO IT
IN A WAY THAT DOESN'T EITHER
DUPLICATE SOMETHING THAT ELSE
ELSE THAT'S OUT THERE, BUT ALSO
IS VERY CLEAR ABOUT, LIKE I WAS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT, OKAY, HOW
DO THIS IS VERY PURPOSELY SAYS,
THEY DO IT ON PURPOSE, RIGHT?
AND SO YOU CAN INFER, BUT IT
BECOMES DIFFICULT TO PROVE THE
PURPOSEFUL UNLESS IT'S SOMETHING
THAT'S JUST SO EGREGIOUS THAT
THAT YOU SAY, LOOK, THIS IS
BEING DONE ON PURPOSE IN ORDER
TO DEFRAUD PEOPLE OF THEIR
HOUSES OR TO TAKE MONEY AWAY
FROM THEM. AND THEN I WAS TRYING
TO FIGURE OUT HOW. SO YOU HAVE A
BROKER THAT'S DOING THE WORK,
AND THEN IT'S TEN YEARS DOWN THE
ROAD, AND THAT BROKER HAS MOVED
ON TO OTHER THINGS. AND IS IT
THE MORTGAGE COMPANY THAT SHOULD
BE HELD RESPONSIBLE AND THEN
SUBJECT TO CRIMINAL PENALTIES,
OR DO YOU ARE YOU YOU DO YOU
JUST SAY, SORRY, WE CAN'T FIND
THE BROKER. WE'RE NOT SURE WHERE
HE IS. SO. SO, THANK YOU,
SENATOR, GOOD QUESTION, A COUPLE
I'LL TAKE AN INITIAL SHOT AT IT,
AND THEN MR. VOSLER CAN CAN
ELABORATE, NUMBER ONE, I SHOULD
NOTE THAT THE, DA'S LED BY THE
CONSUMER PROTECTION DAS ARE IN
SUPPORT OF THIS BILL. THAT, TO
ME, IS INDICATIVE OF THE
CHALLENGES THAT MANY PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS ARE HAVING RIGHT
NOW, EVEN THOUGH IN THE RELEVANT
PENAL CODE SECTION NOT TO GET
TOO WIEDZY HERE THERE'S A
SUBDIVISION A AND A SUBDIVISION
B, THEY SEEM CLEAR ENOUGH TO US,
BUT THERE'S ENOUGH PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS OUT THERE WHO ARE
THINKING THAT MORTGAGE FRAUD IS
A CERTAIN THING OR A DIFFERENT
THING. AND WHEN LITERALLY CASES
HAVE BEEN PRESENTED TO THEM THAT
SEEM PAINFULLY CLEAR TO CFC, TO
MR. VOSLER, TO OTHERS WHO'VE
PAID ATTENTION TO IT, THEY'RE
NOT TAKING THEM UP. NOW, SOME OF
THAT MIGHT BE RESOURCE
LIMITATIONS. AND THE THINGS
THAT, AS YOU KNOW ALL TOO WELL,
SENATOR, PUBLIC PROSECUTORS DEAL
WITH ALL THE TIME, BUT THEY, BUT
THIS SPECIFIC SORT OF TYPES OF
SCAM AND FRAUD WITH THE BRIDGE
LOAN AND THE COMMERCIAL HAS
REALLY BEGUN TO EXPLODE. AND
WHEN I NOTED IN MY OPEN THAT THE
NOTICE OF DEFAULT IS
INCREASINGLY BECOMING A LEAD
GENERATOR FOR FRAUD, THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT WE'RE GOING TO
LOOK AT IN THE FUTURE, BECAUSE
IT'S A PUBLIC DOCKET DOCUMENT,
AND WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE IT A
PRIVATE DOCUMENT, BUT AT THE
SAME TIME, WHEN IT'S BEING USED
FOR SUCH A NEFARIOUS PURPOSE, IT
REALLY GIVES US PAUSE. AND
ULTIMATELY, IT'S THAT SIGNATURE.
AND I'LL BE QUIET THERE AND
DEFER TO MR. VOSLER ABOUT MORE
DETAILS. SO I WANT TO BE
EXTREMELY CLEAR. WE'RE NOT
SUGGESTING THAT PROSECUTORS OR
ANYBODY SHOULD GO AND, YOU KNOW,
START PROSECUTING FRAUD AGAINST
LENDERS WHO WEREN'T INVOLVED IN
LOAN ORIGINATION, WEREN'T
INVOLVED IN ANY FRAUD. WE'RE NOT
SAYING THAT. AND YOU KNOW, I
THINK THE ANALYSIS MAKES PRETTY
CLEAR THAT THERE'S AT LEAST SOME
AMBIGUITY ABOUT WHETHER THE KIND
OF CONDUCT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT
TODAY IS COVERED UNDER EXISTING
LAW. YOU KNOW, MY EXPERIENCE
WORKING WITH PROSECUTORS, AND
I'M TALKING ABOUT MAJOR MILLS OF
50 PLUS EMPLOYEES WHO ARE
CALLING PEOPLE ALL OVER THE
STATE TO BRING THEM DOWN AND
STEER THEM INTO UNSUITABLE
LOANS. THIS INCLUDES A 79 YEAR
OLD CLIENT OF MINE WHO'S NEVER
WORKED A DAY IN HER LIFE AND
DOESN'T SPEAK ENGLISH, AND YET
SHE'S TAKING OUT A COMMERCIAL
LOAN THAT REQUIRES HER TO PAY
$1.4 MILLION IN A YEAR. AND SO
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT CLEAR FRAUD
WITH CLEAR INTENT. YOU KNOW, HAD
THESE PEOPLE JUST LOOKED AT HER
TAX STATEMENTS OR HER DRIVER'S
LICENSE, THEY'D SEE SHE LIVES IN
THE PROPERTY. SHE DOESN'T HAVE
ANY WORK HISTORY. AND WE WANT TO
BE ABLE TO GO AFTER THOSE
BROKERS THAT ARE THAT ARE, THAT
ARE STEERING PEOPLE INTO
UNSUITABLE LOANS TO STEAL THEIR
HOME EQUITY. AND SO, YOU KNOW,
WITH THE QUESTIONS ABOUT WHETHER
THESE ARE COVERED UNDER THE
EXISTING PENAL CODE, YOU KNOW,
WE WANTED TO MAKE IT REALLY
CLEAR THAT THE ACT WITH WITH THE
INTENT TO DEFRAUD, OF STEERING A
BORROWER INTO AN UNSUITABLE LOAN
TO EVADE THOSE CONSUMER
PROTECTION LAWS, THAT THAT ACT
IN AND OF ITSELF IS A CRIMINAL,
IS A CRIMINAL OFFENSE. AND WE
WANT TO MAKE IT REALLY EASY FOR
PROSECUTORS WHO ROBERT HAS
ALREADY SAID HAVE SUPPORTED THIS
BILL. AND SO I HOPE THAT
ANSWERED YOUR QUESTION. YES, I
APPRECIATE THAT IT. WHAT WAS
CONFUSING TO ME IS THE KNOWING
WHEN YOU START GETTING INTO THE
KNOWING OR PURPOSEFUL, I MEAN,
THE BOTTOM LINE IS IF YOU STEER
SOMEBODY INTO THOSE LOANS, YOU
DON'T. THERE'S NO INFERENCE THAT
YOU DON'T KNOW WHAT YOU'RE
DOING. YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I MEAN, IN OTHER WORDS, YOU'RE
STEERING THEM INTO THOSE KINDS
OF LOANS. ARE IS A PREDATORY
ACT. I GUESS THAT'S WHERE I WAS
COMING FROM. IS TO IS I WAS
LOOKING AT IT FROM THE
PERSPECTIVE OF WHAT DO YOU HAVE
TO PROVE? AND AND SO THAT'S,
THAT'S WHAT'S DIFFERENT ABOUT
SOME OF THE OTHER STATUTES THAT.
YEAH, SENATOR, THESE MILLS
WOULDN'T EXIST. I MEAN,
OBVIOUSLY THEY'RE PLAYING WITH A
LITTLE BIT OF A GRAY AREA HERE.
RIGHT. AND, AND, AND WE THINK
THAT IN THE RELEVANT PENAL CODE
SECTION, THERE'S, THERE'S FOUR
PROVISIONS, TWO PROPOSED BY THIS
BILL, THERE'S A ONE AND A TWO.
WE THINK THERE ARE PLENTY PROD.
BUT WHEN THOSE CONVERSATIONS ARE
OCCURRING WITH PUBLIC
PROSECUTORS AND ALSO WITH WITH
PRIVATE ATTORNEYS SUCH AS MR.
VOSSLER, IT BECOMES ALMOST
INSURMOUNTABLE. WE THINK IT'S TO
CFC. IT'S OBVIOUS, BUT I THINK
WE NEED THAT THAT CLARITY. NOW
OBVIOUSLY THIS IS SOMETHING
WE'RE GOING TO CONTINUE TO WORK
ON. WE'VE HAD ACTUALLY VERY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE PLAYERS FROM THE INDUSTRY
WHO'VE BEEN INVOLVED IN OUR
STAKEHOLDER CONVERSATIONS. THEY
HAVE BEEN THE FIRST TO SAY, WE
DON'T DO THIS RIGHT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT OTHER FOLKS. I
WOULD LOVE TO CRACK DOWN ON SOME
OF THOSE MILLS THAT ARE
OCCURRING. SEEMS LIKE A LOT OF
THEM ARE DOWN IN ORANGE COUNTY.
FOR LORD KNOWS WHAT REASON. BUT
I'D LOVE TO CRACK DOWN ON THOSE
AND WE WILL WORK ON THAT. YOU
KNOW ME WELL ENOUGH TO KNOW THAT
WE WILL BE DILIGENT ABOUT WAYS
IN WHICH TO GET AT THAT STUFF,
BUT AT THIS ADDITIONAL AND
AGAIN, THE JURISDICTIONAL ISSUE
WITH PUBLIC SAFETY IN THIS
COMMITTEE, BUT THIS ADDITIONAL
CLARIFICATION TO THE PENAL CODE,
WE FEEL LIKE BASED ON WHERE
WE'RE AT RIGHT NOW IS NECESSARY.
AND THE FACT THAT THE DA'S LED
BY THE CONSUMER PROTECTION FOLKS
WHO DO THESE CASES, AGREE TO US,
SEEMS TO MEET THAT THAT HURDLE.
GOT IT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU
VERY MUCH. I APPRECIATE IT. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS
MEMBERS. SO I HAVE A QUESTION
AND I'M JUST CURIOUS IF EITHER
OF YOU IN SUPPORT OF THE BILL
CAN, TALK A LITTLE BIT ABOUT
WHAT THE OPPOSITION HAS SAID, I
WAS A LITTLE SURPRISED THAT THIS
ESSENTIALLY CREATES, A NEW
CRIME. PROBABLY MORE SURPRISED
BECAUSE I THINK OUR LEGISLATURE
HAS BEEN, REALLY AWARE OF THAT.
AND I JUST WONDER IF YOU CAN
SPEAK TO THE OPPOSITION'S
COMMENTS, IT'S A UNIQUE, DOUBLE
REFERRAL. IT'S NOT ONE THAT YOU
SEE IN BANKING OFTEN, RIGHT, TO
HAVE TO GO THROUGH BANKING AND
ALSO THROUGH PUBLIC SAFETY, SO
JUST GENERALLY, IF YOU CAN SPEAK
TO SOME OF WHAT THE OPPOSITION'S
CONCERNS WERE AS IT RELATES TO
THE CRIMINAL SECTION CODE THAT
IS BEING, ADDRESSED HERE. YEAH.
I'LL BE VERY BRIEF. AND I DON'T
WANT TO DANCE ON THE HEAD OF A
PIN. SENATOR, YOUR POINT IS WELL
TAKEN. IT'S BEEN PART IT'S BEEN
A MAJOR COMPONENT OF THE
CONVERSATIONS THAT WE'VE HAD
WITH THE STAKEHOLDERS. AND NOT
JUST MISS MCDONALD, BUT THE
OTHER FOLKS FROM THE INDUSTRY
WHO ARE NOT AT THE TABLE RIGHT
NOW, THE, THE, I, I WOULD ASSERT
THAT IT DOESN'T CREATE A NEW
CRIME, ALTHOUGH I THINK
TECHNICALLY YOU'RE YOU'RE
CORRECT. RIGHT WE THINK THAT
THAT PROVISION THREE AND FOUR
ADDING TO, 532 F OF THE PENAL
CODE FURTHER CLARIFY ACTS THAT
ONE COULD ARGUE MIGHT BE
SUBSUMED NUMBER ONE AND TWO. BUT
ARE NOT GETTING PROSECUTED OR
LITIGATED PRIVATELY, BUT
PARTICULARLY PROSECUTED BY THE
PUBLIC PROSECUTORS. AND SO
THAT'S THE REASON FOR WE THINK
WE THINK IT'S MORE OF A
CLARIFICATION OF THE PENAL CODE,
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU. BUT
AGAIN, I DON'T WANT TO DANCE ON
THE HEAD OF A PIN ABOUT WHETHER,
YOU KNOW, DOES THAT CREATE A NEW
CRIME? IF YOU ADD A PROVISION
THREE AND FOUR AND YOU COULD BE
CHARGED UNDER THREE AND FOUR, WE
GET IT. BUT WE THINK IT'S MORE
CLARIFYING OF THINGS THAT TO CFC
ARE SUBSUMED UNDER ONE AND TWO
BUT AREN'T BEING CHARGED, IF I
MAY. YOU KNOW, MY UNDERSTANDING
AND I OBVIOUSLY DON'T WANT TO
SPEAK FOR THE INDUSTRY IS THE
INDUSTRY COALITION IS THAT
THEY'RE JUST SAYING THAT, YOU
KNOW, THESE PREDATORY ACTIONS
THAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT,
THEY'RE BAD AND THEY'RE ARGUING
THAT THEY'RE COVERED UNDER
EXISTING LAW. I THINK THE
ANALYSIS SHOWS THAT TO BE AN
AMBIGUOUS QUESTION AT BEST. AND
I THINK I'D ALSO LIKE TO ADD,
YOU KNOW, EVEN IF THE EXISTING
LAW DOES COVER WHAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT, ONE OF THE
REASONS WHY I DON'T USE IT IN MY
CASES IS BECAUSE EXISTING LAW
SAYS THAT THE BROKER, THEY'RE
THEY'RE LIABLE IF THEY
FACILITATE A MISSTATEMENT,
RIGHT. IF I ARGUE ON BEHALF OF
THE BORROWER THAT THE BROKERS
FACILITATE A MISSTATEMENT, IT
SURE FEELS LIKE I'M THROWING MY
CLIENT UNDER THE BUS. AND I
DON'T WANT TO DO THAT. WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT FRAUD THAT
ORIGINATES WITH THE BROKER. AND
I REALLY THINK THIS THIS PENAL
CODE STATUTE NEEDS TO HAVE
SOMETHING THAT FOCUSES
SPECIFICALLY ON THAT. SO I'M NOT
THROWING MY CLIENT UNDER THE BUS
EVERY TIME I NEED TO ARGUE, THE
BROKER DID SOMETHING BAD. SORRY.
WELL THANK YOU. AND I THINK
THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT, I DON'T
KNOW ANYBODY HERE THAT WANTS TO
SEE THIS FRAUD OR IS OKAY WITH
THIS FRAUD AND CERTAINLY DOESN'T
WANT TO TAKE ACTION. SO, YOU
KNOW, IT'S JUST IT WAS A UNIQUE
THING THAT I CAUGHT IN THE BILL,
IT'S NOT COMMON THAT, YOU KNOW,
OUR BILLS ARE DOUBLE REFERRED TO
JUDICI. I'M SORRY. VERY COMMON
TO DO DISH. NOT COMMON AS COMMON
TO PUBLIC SAFETY, BUT IT IS
SOMETHING THAT I THINK, YOU
KNOW, MERITED JUST A PUBLIC
CONVERSATION ABOUT WHAT THE
THINKING IS. AND THEN I
APPRECIATE THE CLARIFICATION. I
DON'T KNOW IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO
RESPOND TO THAT. NO, NO, JUST
JUST TO SAY THAT WE DO WE DO
UNDERSTAND OUR INTERPRETATION IS
THAT THE CURRENT LAW IS QUITE
BROAD AND WOULD CAPTURE, TARGET
THE, THE FRAUD THAT IS OUT
THERE, WHICH WE AGREE WITH THE
INTENTION OF THE BILL. WE DO NOT
WANT TO SEE THAT EITHER. SO
APPRECIATE THE ONGOING DIALOG.
WOULD APPRECIATE SOME FURTHER
ANALYSIS, AS TO THE QUESTIONS
THAT WE'VE BEEN DISCUSSING IN.
THANKS FOR YOUR TIME. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT, MEMBERS, SEEING NO
OTHER QUESTIONS. SENATOR, WOULD
YOU LIKE TO CLOSE ON BEHALF OF
THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER RESPECTFULLY
ASK FOR AN AYE VOTE? THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. SO THAT BILL DOES
HAVE A MOTION. IT'S DUE PASS TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY.
SORRY. DO PASS, AS AMENDED TO
THE COMMITTEE ON PUBLIC SAFETY,
AND SO WE WILL GO AHEAD. WE NEED
A MOTION. WE HAVE A MOTION FROM
SENATOR CAVALLERO, AND WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL 30 108, MOTION IS
DUE. PASS, AS AMENDED TO SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY. SENATOR LIMÓN, I
LIMON I NILO I NILO I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I MINH.
NGUYEN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
HAS FOUR. ALL RIGHT. THAT, BILL
HAS FOUR VOTES IN SUPPORT, AND
WE WILL, PUT THE BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. ALL RIGHT.
NOW WE ARE LOOKING Ó. WE HAVE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER LOWE HERE. HI.
HELLO.
ALL RIGHT, SO THIS IS FILE ITEM
11, AB 3100. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH, MADAM CHAIR AND
COLLEAGUES, FOR ALLOWING ME TO
PRESENT ASSEMBLY BILL 3100. THIS
BILL WILL HELP TO ENSURE THAT WE
EASE THE BURDEN ON INDIVIDUALS
GOING THROUGH DIVORCE BY
ALLOWING ONE PARTY TO ASSUME THE
MORTGAGE IF THEY MEET THE
NECESSARY QUALIFICATIONS. AND I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
GREAT. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
FEEL FREE TO COME FORWARD.
AFTERNOON. ANNA BUCK, ON BEHALF
OF THE CALIFORNIA ASSOCIATION OF
REALTORS IN STRONG SUPPORT.
GREAT. THANK YOU. SEEING NO
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT, ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS? COMMENTS SEEING NONE.
WE WELCOME A MOTION. ALL RIGHT.
SENATOR CAVALETTO MOVES THE
BILL. I THINK WE SHOULD HAVE
MADE THE ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S SPEAK
A LITTLE BIT LONGER. I HAVE
THREE MORE. I HAVE THREE MORE.
HE'S PRESENTING OTHER BILLS, SO
WE WILL HEAR HIS BEAUTIFUL VOICE
EVEN MORE. ALL RIGHT. SO SEEING
NONE, WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE VOTE.
GREAT. THANK YOU, SO THAT IS,
ASSEMBLY BILL 3100. THIS BILL
HAS A MOTION Dð PASS, AND WE
REFER TO THE COMMITTEE ON
JUDICIARY. ASSEMBLY BILL 3100.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR LIMÓN A LIMÓN
I NILO I NILO I BRADFORD.
CABALLERO. CABALLERO I MINH
NGUYEN PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I
IS FOR GREAT THAT. BILL HAS FOUR
VOTES IN SUPPORT, AND WE WILL
PUT THAT BILL ON CALL. AND NOW I
UNDERSTAND YOU ARE PRESENTING A
COUPLE OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON'S BILLS, WE CAN BEGIN
WITH FILE ITEM FIVE, AB 1934.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, MADAM.
MADAM CHAIR AND COLLEAGUES, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ON BEHALF
OF ASSEMBLYMEMBER TIM GRAYSON,
THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL 1934, TO
HELP ENSURE THAT THERE IS AN
EXTENSION OF THE REQUIRED
LICENSURE DATE FROM JULY 1ST,
2025 TO JULY 1ST, 2026. THIS IS
IN RESPECT TO THE PREVIOUS
LEGISLATIVE PROPOSALS SIGNED BY
OUR GOVERNOR ON ASSEMBLY BILL
39, WHICH CREATED A
COMPREHENSIVE LICENSING PROGRAM
FOR CRYPTO COMPANIES OPERATING
IN CALIFORNIA. APPRECIATE THE
CONSIDERATION OF THIS MEASURE
AND I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AYE
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? LUKE
REIDENBACH, ON BEHALF OF THE
AUTHOR FOR ANY TECHNICAL
QUESTIONS. THANK YOU. ANY
ADDITIONAL WITNESSES IN SUPPORT?
ROBERT HARO WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA. WE
HAVE NO OFFICIAL POSITION ON THE
BILL. WE WERE THE SPONSORS OF AB
39, WE, ARE WE HAVE MET WITH THE
DEPARTMENT ABOUT THE ROLLOUT OF
THIS. THE ANALYSIS DOES A GOOD
JOB. IT IS A SIGNIFICANT TASK,
AND WE DON'T DOUBT THAT FOR A
SECOND. WE DO WORRY A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT A YEAR LONG DELAY BEYOND
AGAIN, THIS IS A BILL THAT WAS
VETOED YEAR ONE SIGNED YEAR TWO
AFTER BEING MODIFIED WITH A
DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION ALREADY
IN THE BILL THAT WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW LAST YEAR. SO WE WOULD LIKE
SOMETHING A LITTLE BIT SHORTER.
WE HAVE MET WITH THE DEPARTMENT.
WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY
GET THIS RIGHT, AND BUT WE WANT
TO ALSO MAKE SURE THAT BECAUSE
OF THE TIMING OF THE CALENDAR,
IT DOESN'T WIND UP CANDIDLY
BEING SOMETHING THAT THE NEXT
ADMINISTRATION, WHOEVER THAT MAY
BE, WINDS UP HANDLING. AND WE'RE
WORRIED A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THAT
TIMING. THANK YOU. THANK YOU.
ALL RIGHT. ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. ALL RIGHT. SEEING
NONE MEMBERS. ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A
MOTION BY SENATOR CAVALLERO
SEEING NO QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS,
THANK YOU FOR BRINGING THIS
FORWARD. AND WE WILL GO AHEAD.
DO WOULD YOU LIKE TO CLOSE? I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
THANK YOU ALL RIGHT, SO THIS
BILL HAS A DO PASS AND REFERRED
TO THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY,
WE'LL GO AHEAD AND CALL THE ROLL
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1934. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR LIMÓN, A LIMÓN I NILO I
NILO I BRADFORD CABALLERO.
CABALLERO I MINH NGUYEN
PORTANTINO PORTANTINO I SPOOR.
ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL HAS FOUR.
WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON CALL,
AND NOW WE WILL DO THE SECOND
BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON,
PRESENTED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER LOH
AB 2017. THANK YOU VERY MUCH,
MADAM CHAIR. AND COLLEAGUES, FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT ASSEMBLY
BILL 2017, WHICH WOULD HELP TO
PREVENT FEE CREEP IN THE BANKING
INDUSTRY BY PROHIBITING STATE
CHARTERED FINANCIAL INSTITUTIONS
FROM CHARGING A NONSUFFICIENT
FUND OR NSF. THE FEE TO A
CONSUMER FOR A TRANSACTION
DECLINED INSTANTANEOUS OR NEARLY
INSTANTANEOUS AS WELL. TO WITH
US HERE TODAY IN SUPPORT IS,
ROBERT HARRELL WITH THE CONSUMER
FEDERATION OF CALIFORNIA AND
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR OUR VOTE.
GREAT. THANK YOU, I'LL BE BRIEF.
THESE ARE TRANSACTIONS THAT HAVE
BEEN DENIED. SO YOU DON'T WANT
TO GET A NON-SUFFICIENT FUNDS
CHARGE FOR A TRANSACTION THAT'S
BEEN DENIED, TO US, THIS SEEMS
LIKE OBVIOUS COMMON SENSE. AND
TO BE CANDID, WE'RE A LITTLE BIT
PERPLEXED AND CONCERNED. WHY THE
CREDIT UNIONS CONTINUE TO OPPOSE
THIS BILL WHEN THEY SAY THEY
DON'T DO IT. BUT WE URGE AND I
VOTE. GREAT. THANK YOU. ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT OF
THE BILL? ALL RIGHT. SEEING NONE
, WE WILL ASK FOR ANY WITNESSES
IN OPPOSITION TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD. SEEING NO WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. WE WILL BRING IT
BACK TO THE MEMBERS. ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? ALL
RIGHT. SENATOR CAVALLERO MOVES
THE BILL, SEEING NONE. VICE
CHAIR NILA. HAS THE CREDIT
UNIONS REMOVED THEIR OPPOSITION?
YEP. THEY HAVE NOT. ALL RIGHT.
ALL RIGHT. SO SEEING NO OTHER
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE RESPECTFULLY ASK
BROUGH. THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT, SO
THIS IS ASSEMBLYMEMBER'S. A B
29. SORRY. IT'S, 2017. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AND REFER TO
THE COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL ASSEMBLY
BILL 2017. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR
LIMÓN I LIMON I NILO I NILO I.
BRADFORD CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
MINH. NGUYEN PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I FOR. ALL RIGHT. SO
THAT HAS FOUR. WE WILL PUT THE
BILL ON CALL AND WE HAVE ONE
FINAL, BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AND ALSO PRESENTING. YES
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. ALL RIGHT. HE'S
DOING THE WHOLE THING, SO
ASSEMBLY BILL 2993, THANK YOU
VERY MUCH, MADAM CHAIR, FOR THIS
FINAL BILL BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON, THIS IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2993, WHICH WILL ESTABLISH
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
IN THE HOME IMPROVEMENT LENDING
INDUSTRY. THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE COMMITTEE STAFF FOR YOUR
WORK ON THIS AND ACCEPTING THE
AMENDMENTS ON BEHALF OF MR.
GRAYSON, AS REFERENCED IN THE
ANALYSIS BEFORE THE MEMBERS
TODAY. OF COURSE, WE WANT TO
HELP ENSURE THAT WE SHOULD THIS
BILL MOVE FORWARD, THAT WE WORK
WITH OPPOSITION TO ADDRESS ANY
OUTSTANDING ISSUES. THIS BILL
ALSO ESTABLISHES NEW RULES FOR
FINANCE LENDERS WHO MAKE HOME
IMPROVEMENT LOANS. AND IN DOING
SO, THIS BILL SUPPORTS THE
EFFORTS OF THE CONTRACTOR STATE
LICENSE BOARD TO REIN IN ON
UNSCRUPULOUS ACTORS IN THIS
SPACE AND RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
AYE VOTE AND HAVE ADDITIONAL
WITNESSES HERE IN SUPPORT.
GREAT. THANK YOU. WE WILL BEGIN
WITH THE WITNESSES IN SUPPORT.
GOOD AFTERNOON, CHAIR AND
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. MY NAME IS
AUDREY THORNTON AND I'M A SENIOR
ATTORNEY AT HOUSING AND ECONOMIC
RIGHTS ADVOCATES. WE'RE A
NONPROFIT LEGAL SERVICES
ORGANIZATION THAT SERVES LOW TO
MODERATE INCOME CLIENTS,
CONSUMERS THROUGHOUT THE STATE
OF CALIFORNIA, AND WE HELP THEM
WITH THEIR DEBT CREDIT AND
HOUSEHOLD FINANCIAL FINANCIAL
CONCERNS. WE SUPPORT AB 2993
BECAUSE IT WOULD ADD VERY
IMPORTANT CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
FOR HOME IMPROVEMENT. LOAN
BORROWERS AND HOME IMPROVEMENT
FINANCING HAS EMERGED IN THE
LAST FEW YEARS AS A NICHE
INDUSTRY IN THE IN THE LENDING
INDUSTRY THAT HAS SOME UNIQUE
COMPONENTS WHICH HAVE GIVEN RISE
TO MANY PROBLEMS. THESE INCLUDE
THE FACT THAT THE FINANCE
LENDERS ARE DEPUTIZING
CONTRACTORS AND THEIR
SALESPEOPLE TO GO DOOR TO DOOR
AND TO TELEMARKET NOT ONLY THE
HOME IMPROVEMENTS THAT THEY'RE
SELLING, BUT ALSO THE FINANCING
ITSELF. IN ADDITION, THE FINANCE
LENDERS ARE PAYING THE LOAN
PROCEEDS DIRECTLY TO THE
CONTRACTORS AND NOT TO THE
HOMEOWNER. SO WE SEE CONTRACTORS
THAT ARE SELLING A HOME
IMPROVEMENT TO A VULNERABLE
CONSUMER AND MISREPRESENT
MISREPRESENTING THE TERMS OF THE
FINANCING. IN FACT, MANY OF OUR
CLIENTS DON'T EVEN KNOW THAT
THEY'RE SIGNING UP FOR A HOME
IMPROVEMENT LOAN. THEY A LOT OF
IT'S DONE THROUGH ELECTRONIC
SIGNATURES ON ELECTRONIC TABLETS
AND SO WHEN THEY'RE PUTTING IN
THEIR CONSENT TO THE HOME
IMPROVEMENT CONTRACT, THEY DON'T
REALIZE THEY'RE ALSO SIGNING UP
FOR FINANCING AND EXPENSIVE LOAN
. OFTEN IN THESE CASES, THE WORK
IS NOT FINISHED BEFORE THE LOAN
PROCEEDS ARE DISBURSED BECAUSE
IN MANY OF OUR CASES, THE
CONTRACTOR DISAPPEARS ONCE
THEY'RE PAID AND THE HOMEOWNER
STARTS GETTING BILLED BY THE
LENDER FOR WORK THAT'S NOT
FINISHED OR IT'S NOT FUNCTIONAL,
OR THE PRICE IS MUCH MORE THAN
THEY'VE BEEN PROMISED. SO RIGHT
NOW, UNDER CURRENT LAW, THE BIG
PROBLEM IS, IS THAT WHEN WE
RAISE THESE ISSUES WITH THE
LENDER, THE LENDERS RESPONSE IS,
WELL, WE'RE NOT RESPONSIBLE FOR
WHAT THE CONTRACTOR TOLD YOU.
YOU STILL HAVE TO PAY US BACK ON
THE LOAN BECAUSE YOU SIGNED UP
FOR IT. THIS HAS CREATED
PROBLEMS FOR SO MANY HOMEOWNERS
IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE ARE SO
MANY PEOPLE THAT WE CAN'T HELP
BECAUSE THE LAW IS JUST NOT
STRONG ENOUGH IN THIS AREA. SO
AB 2993 REALLY ADDRESSES THESE
PROBLEMS. IT SETS UP A SYSTEM
WHEREBY THE HOME IMPROVEMENT
LENDER HAS TO COMMUNICATE ORALLY
WITH THE CUSTOMER, HAS TO TELL
THEM THE TERMS OF THE LOAN, HAS
TO MAKE SURE THAT THEY REALIZE
THEY'RE GETTING INTO A LOAN TO
PAY FOR THESE HOME IMPROVEMENTS,
AND IT WILL NOT RELEASE THE
FINAL FUNDS TO THE CONTRACTOR,
AND IT WILL NOT START BILLING
THE CUSTOMER UNTIL THEY HAVE
WHAT THEY'VE SIGNED UP FOR AND
THEY GET THE PRODUCT THEY WERE
LOOKING FOR. SO WE URGE YOUR
SUPPORT FOR AB 2993. AND I'D
LIKE TO HAVE MY COLLEAGUE DANIEL
ALPER, WHO IS AN ATTORNEY FOR
ONE OF OUR HOME IMPROVEMENT
CLIENTS, SHARE A STORY FROM A
CLIENT THAT ILLUSTRATES WHY THIS
BILL IS NECESSARY. THANK YOU.
GREAT. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
CHAIR AND COMMITTEE MEMBERS IN
2018, THE CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE
PASSED CONSUMER PROTECTIONS
UNDER THE CALIFORNIA FINANCING
LAW THAT APPLY TO HOME
IMPROVEMENT LOANS UNDER THE
PROPERTY ASSESSED CLEAN ENERGY
PROGRAM, THESE PROTECTIONS
CURRENTLY, MANY OF THOSE
PROTECTIONS DO NOT APPLY TO
UNSECURED LOANS. FOR EXAMPLE,
UNDER STREETS AND HIGHWAYS CODE
5913, A PROGRAM ADMINISTRATOR
AND THE PROPERTY ASSESSED CLEAN
ENERGY PROGRAM MUST PERFORM A
TERM'S CONFIRMATION CALL BEFORE
THE CONTRACT IS SIGNED FOR THE
HOME IMPROVEMENT LOAN, ENSURING
THAT THE HOMEOWNER IS AWARE OF
THE TERMS IN FOR AN UNSECURED
LOAN. THESE PROTECTIONS ARE ARE
NOT APPLICABLE, AND SO AB 2993
BRIDGES THE GAP AND CREATES
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS FOR
UNSECURED LOANS THAT ARE
ESSENTIAL FOR THE MANY
HOMEOWNERS THAT WE SEE. A
SIGNIFICANT NUMBER OF MY CLIENTS
ARE SENIORS, THOSE WHO ARE
DISABLED, LIVING ON FIXED
INCOMES, AND ARE NOT ABLE TO
AFFORD THESE LOANS. IN ONE CASE,
A HOMEOWNER WHO IS 67 YEARS OLD,
WIDOW WAS SOLICITED AT HER HOME
MULTIPLE TIMES BY A SOLAR
CONTRACTOR. SHE WAS TOLD THAT
SHE WOULD NOT HAVE TO REPAY THE
LOAN, THAT THE LOAN WAS THROUGH
A GOVERNMENT PROGRAM THAT WOULD
BE REPAID WHEN THE SALESPERSON
PRESENTED THE CONTRACT TO THE
HOMEOWNER, IT WAS ON A TABLET
AND THE SALESPERSON ASKED HER TO
TAP ON THE TABLET TO SIGN THE
DOCUMENTS. THE HOMEOWNER HAS
VISION TROUBLE, AND SHE ASKED
FOR A HARD COPY BEFORE SHE
SIGNED ANYTHING. THE SALESPERSON
REFUSED TO PROVIDE A HARD COPY
AND INSISTED THAT THE TABLET
THAT SHE WAS ABOUT TO TAP ON
WERE THE HAD THE VERY SAME TERMS
THAT HE REPRESENTED TO HER. WHEN
THE HOMEOWNER RECEIVED A BILLING
STATEMENT BEFORE THE SOLAR
PANELS EVEN BECAME OPERATIONAL,
SHE CONTACTED THE LENDER AND
DISCOVERED FOR THE VERY FIRST
TIME THAT SHE HAD BEEN SIGNED UP
FOR A LOAN THAT OBLIGATED TO HER
TO PAY $85,000, A SUM THAT SHE
COULD NEVER AFFORD TO REPAY. AND
SO THIS BILL, A, B TWO, 993, IS
ESSENTIAL TO PROTECT VULNERABLE
CITIZENS FROM FRAUD. WE URGE
YOUR SUPPORT. THANK YOU. GREAT.
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? PLEASE
COME FORWARD. ROBERT HERLE WITH
THE CONSUMER FOUNDATION ON THE
CONSUMER FEDERATION OF
CALIFORNIA IN SUPPORT OF THIS
BILL. THANK YOU. GREAT. THANK
YOU. ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
OR WITH CONCERNS, PLEASE COME
FORWARD. CAN I COME ON THERE?
THANK YOU, MY NAME IS, JOSH
CHURKO. I'M THE DEPUTY DIRECTOR
WITH THE CALIFORNIA SOLAR AND
STORAGE ASSOCIATION. THANK YOU
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY, TO SPEAK
TODAY, CONSUMER PROTECTION IS A
MATTER OF THE HIGHEST PRIORITY
FOR MY ASSOCIATION, AND WE KNOW
THAT OF THE 2 MILLION ROOFTOP
SOLAR AND STORAGE INSTALLATIONS,
THE VAST MAJORITY HAVE HAD NO
ISSUES, BUT WE REALIZE THERE
HAVE BEEN BAD ACTORS, AND THIS
BILL WOULD CODIFY SOME IMPORTANT
CONSUMER PROTECTIONS THAT COULD
HOPEFULLY MITIGATE THOSE HARMS.
SO WE'VE BEEN WORKING VERY
CLOSELY WITH ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON, THE ASSEMBLY BANKING
COMMITTEE STAFF AND THE SPONSORS
OF THIS BILL, WE REALLY
APPRECIATE THAT THROUGH THESE
NEGOTIATIONS, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON REMOVED THE MOST
DIFFICULT SECTION OF THE BILL
FOR US, WHICH WAS SECTION TEN.
SO DUE TO THE FRUITFUL NATURE OF
THOSE NEGOTIATIONS, WE HAVE A
SUPPORTIVE AMEND POSITION. I DID
WANT TO FLAG A FEW OF THE
REMAINING AREAS THAT WE HAVE,
THAT, IF ADDRESSED, WOULD RESULT
IN A IN A FULL SUPPORT POSITION.
SO FIRST, THIS BILL ONLY APPLIES
TO CALIFORNIA FINANCIAL LENDERS
OR CFLS, HOWEVER, THERE ARE
LENDERS THAT ARE OWNED BY A BANK
THAT ARE INDISTINGUISHABLE FROM
CFLS AND WOULD BE UNAFFECTED BY
THIS BILL, INDEED, THIS BILL
COULD ACTUALLY PUT THEM AT A
COMPETITIVE ADVANTAGE AND
POTENTIALLY SOME OF THE PROBLEMS
FLAGGED, JUST RECENTLY WOULDN'T
GO AWAY. SO TO ADDRESS THIS, WE
THINK THE BILL SHOULD BE APPLIED
EQUALLY TO ALL LENDERS THAT PAY
CONTRACTORS DIRECTLY, WHETHER OR
NOT THEY'RE OWNED BY A BANK,
SECOND, THE BILL SAYS A SOLAR
CUSTOMER WILL NOT BEGIN PAYMENT
TO THE LENDER UNTIL THE SOLAR
SYSTEM HAS PERMISSION TO OPERATE
FROM THE UTILITY. THAT'S PTO,
AND THERE'S BEEN A CONFIRMATION
CALL AND A WRITTEN COMPLETION
CERTIFICATE FROM THE CUSTOMER
STATING THAT EVERYTHING'S BEEN
INSTALLED. ADDITIONALLY, THE
CONTRACTOR WOULD NOT RECEIVE THE
FINAL 15% OF THEIR JOB, UNTIL
THESE BENCHMARKS OCCUR. SO WE
HAVE A FEW SUGGESTIONS ON THIS,
PROPOSAL ONE, WE DO NOT THINK
TYING PAYMENT TO PTO IS
APPROPRIATE BECAUSE, CONTRACTORS
HAVE ALMOST NO CONTROL OVER HOW
THE IOUS PROCESS THE
INTERCONNECTION TIMELINE, IT CAN
OFTEN TAKE MANY, MANY MONTHS.
MEANWHILE, THE CONTRACTOR WOULD
BE OUT OF 15% OF THE PAYMENT,
WHICH IS SIGNIFICANT FOR A LOT
OF SMALL CONTRACTORS. SO WE
STRONGLY RECOMMEND THAT A FINAL
PROGRESS PAYMENT OF 5% BE
WITHHELD UNTIL THERE'S PROOF OF
INSPECTION FROM THE RELEVANT
BUILDING AGENCY, WE THINK PROOF
OF INSPECTION FROM THE H.R.
SHOULD ALSO SUFFICE FOR PAYMENT
WITHOUT FURTHER ACTIONS BY THE
CUSTOMER. SO UNDER THIS BILL, IF
A CUSTOMER NEVER COMPLETES THIS
CONFIRMATION CALL, OR THE
COMPLETION CERTIFICATE, THE
SYSTEM IS TECHNICALLY NOT
OPERATIONAL. AND THE CUSTOMER
WOULD NEVER HAVE TO PAY ON THE
LOAN, AND THE CONTRACTOR WOULD
NEVER RECEIVE THE FINAL 15. SO
THE HJS ROLE IS TO INDEPENDENTLY
CONFIRM THAT THE SYSTEM HAS BEEN
INSTALLED. ACCORDING TO DESIGN.
AND SO WE THINK THAT THAT SHOULD
SUFFICE, WE ALSO THINK LENDERS
SHOULD BE ABLE TO SEEK TIMELY
PAYMENTS FROM THE CUSTOMER,
GIVEN THAT THEY ARE OUT OF
POCKET, THE PAYMENT TO THE
CONTRACTOR. SO WE SUGGEST THAT
THE LENDER BE PERMITTED TO SEEK
LOAN PAYMENTS IN AMOUNT IN AN
AMOUNT THAT DO NOT, IN THE
AGGREGATE, EXCEED WHAT'S ALLOWED
UNDER LAW RIGHT NOW, UNTIL THE
SYSTEM PASSES INSPECTION, IN
WHICH THEY CAN COLLECT THE FULL
PAYMENT, WE THINK THIS IS
REASONABLE, PARTICULARLY IF, AS
WE SUPPORT, THE CUSTOMER IS MADE
AWARE DURING THE CONFIRMATION
CALL THAT THERE MAY BE
SITUATIONS WHERE THEY BEGIN
PAYMENT BEFORE THE SYSTEM HAS
BEEN CONNECTED TO THE GRID,
FINALLY, THE BILL REQUIRES ALL
HOME IMPROVEMENT LENDERS TO
CONDUCT A CONFIRMATION CALL WITH
THE BORROWER BEFORE THE LENDING
AGREEMENT HAS BEEN SIGNED AND
BEFORE THE RIGHT TO CANCEL HAS
EXPIRED. WE SUPPORT A
CONFIRMATION CALL. WE THINK IT'S
A USEFUL TOOL IN CONFIRMING THAT
A BORROWER UNDERSTANDS THAT THEY
TOOK OUT A LOAN AND THE Kò
TERMS, AS WELL AS DETECTING
FRAUD AND GIVING THE BORROWERS
THE OPPORTUNITY TO TAKE BACK
THAT TRANSACTION. WE THEREFORE
RECOMMEND THAT THE CALL BE
CONDUCTED AFTER THE LOAN
AGREEMENT IS SIGNED, AND THAT
THE BORROWER BE ALLOWED A
REASONABLE AMOUNT OF TIME TO
CANCEL THE CONTRACT AFTER
COMPLETING THE CALL. SO WE AGAIN
APPRECIATE THE BILL'S
MODIFICATION SO FAR. WE LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH THE BILL'S AUTHOR, BUT I
DID WANT TO FLAG THOSE. THANK.
THAT'S A LOT FOR SUPPORT IF
AMENDED. AGAIN HAVE BEEN
NEGOTIATING IN VERY GOOD FAITH.
SO APPRECIATE THAT. THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER WITNESSES IN, A
CONCERN OR OPPOSITION ROLE? ALL
RIGHT. SEEING NONE, MEMBERS, ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS? ALL
RIGHT. SEE? YES APPRECIATE THE
EXPLANATIONS. AND IT MADE IT
VERY SOMETIMES IT'S HARD TO
FIGURE OUT EXACTLY WHAT PROBLEM
WE'RE TRYING TO SOLVE FOR. AND
SO I REALLY APPRECIATE THE, THE
INFORMATION. AND I AGREE WITH
THE CHAIR A LOT OF AMENDS. BUT
IT'S NOT DONE YET IS WHAT I
UNDERSTAND. SO I EXPECT WE'LL
HAVE MORE. YOU'LL HAVE MORE OF
AN OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO THE TO
THE AUTHOR OF THE BILL, WHICH IS
NOT THE GENTLEMAN HERE BEFORE US
TODAY, BUT BUT WE'LL LOOK
FORWARD TO MAYBE SOME OF THOSE
AMENDMENTS, BEING FRUITFUL
DISCUSSION. SO I WILL MOVE THE
BILL TODAY. GREAT. SENATOR
CAVALETTO MOVES THE BILL. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY OTHER MEMBERS
WITH QUESTIONS. CERTAINLY IT
DOES. YOU KNOW, I'M GLAD SOME
MEMBER GRAYSON IS HAVING LOTS OF
CONVERSATIONS. OF COURSE, YOU
KNOW, PUTTING IN THE WORK FOR
THAT, THIS BILL DOES HAVE A
MOTION OF DUE PASS. BUT FIRST
AMEND AND REFERRED TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY. BUT
BEFORE WE DO THAT, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE? THANK YOU FOR
YOUR GENEROSITY AND GRACIOUSNESS
. ON BEHALF OF ASSEMBLYMAN
GRAYSON, I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
OUR VOTE. THANK YOU, SO WITH
THAT, WE WILL GO AHEAD AND CALL
THE ROLL ASSEMBLY BILL, 2993.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR
LIMÓN I LIMÓN I NILO I NILO I
BRADFORD. CABALLERO. CABALLERO I
MINH. NGUYEN NGUYEN I PORTANTINO
PORTANTINO I HAVE FIVE. ALL
RIGHT. THAT BILL HAS FIVE VOTES.
WE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOWE, FOR ALL YOUR WORK
TODAY. THANK YOU. THANK YOU,
THANK YOU. ALL RIGHT. WE ARE
GOING TO GO THROUGH THE ROLL ONE
MORE TIME. SO WE ARE GOING TO
ASK THAT ANY ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE COME BACK TO BANKING SO
THAT WE CAN, REMOVE THE BILLS
FROM CALL. SO WE'RE GOING TO GO
AHEAD AND START WITH THE
CONSENT. AND I DO WANT TO MAKE
ONE CLARIFICATION, FOR THE
CONSENT, WE HAVE, FILE ITEM
NUMBER TWO, A B 2908, THAT WAS
MISSTATED. SO IT'S 20 908, FILE
ITEM NUMBER FOUR, AB 2067, FILE
ITEM SEVEN, AB 2062 AND FILE
ITEM EIGHT AB 2422. THE CONSENT
CALENDAR. SENATOR BRADFORD
NGUYEN NGUYEN I THAT HAS SIX.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE SIX VOTES. WE
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL.
NEXT. WE WILL GO TO, FILE ITEM
NUMBER ONE, AB 2618. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2618. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR BRADFORD. SENATOR NGUYEN
I WIN I THAT IS SIX. ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS SIX. WE WILL PUT THAT
BILL ON CALL. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM THREE 3148. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3148. MOTION IS DUE PASSED
TO SENATE APPROPRIATIONS.
SENATOR. BRADFORD, SENATOR
NGUYEN Ã NGUYEN I SIX. ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS SIX. WE WILL PUT
THAT BILL ON CALL. NEXT. WE WILL
GO TO FILE ITEM FIVE.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON AB 1934.
ASSEMBLY BILL, 1934. MOTION IS
DUE PASSED TO SENATE APPROPRIATE
OR SORRY. SENATE. JUDICIARY.
SENATOR BRADFORD, SENATOR MINH
FIVE. I NGUYEN OKAY. I THINK I
SAID NGUYEN OR MINH THAT'S OKAY.
SENATOR NGUYEN I THANK YOU. THAT
IS FIVE ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
FIVE. WE WILL PUT THE BILL ON
CALL NEXT. WE WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM SIX BY ASSEMBLYMEMBER
GRAYSON. AB 2017 ASSEMBLY BILL,
2017. MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR
BRADFORD MINH NGUYEN NGUYEN I S
FIVE. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS FIVE.
AND WE WILL PUT THAT BILL ON
CALL. NEXT WE WILL GO TO FILE
ITEM NUMBER NINE, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER GRAYSON 2993. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2993. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR BRADFORD MINH. YOU GOT
THAT ONE. OKAY. ALL RIGHT. SO WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND PUT THAT BILL
ON CALL. NEXT. WE HAVE A FILE
ITEM NUMBER TEN BY ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES. SAWYER AB 3108.
ASSEMBLY BILL 3108 DO PASS AS
AMENDED, TO SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY. SENATOR BRADFORD.
SENATOR MINH, SENATOR NGUYEN I
NGUYEN I THAT IS FIVE AND THE
FINAL ITEM IS FILE ITEM NUMBER
12 BY SHIAVO. AND THAT'S AB 2424
ASSEMBLY. BILL 2424 MOTION IS DO
PASS AS AMENDED, TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR. BRADFORD.
SENATOR NGUYEN I SORRY. THAT'S
OKAY. IS THAT AN EYE? YES. I WAS
WAITING FOR THE MEN FIRST. YEAH
THAT'S OKAY. ALL RIGHT. AND I
DID SKIP FILE ITEM NUMBER 11.
APOLOGIES FOR THAT. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER LOH AB 3100. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3100. MOTION IS DUE PASSED.
THE SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR.
BRADFORD, SENATOR MINH. SENATOR.
NGUYEN NGUYEN I ALL RIGHT. SO WE
WILL PUT THAT BILL ON CALL AND
WE ASK THAT OUR ABSENT MEMBERS
PLEASE COME BACK TO BANKING TO
ADD ON, UNTIL THEN, WE ARE GOING
TO RECESS RIGHT. AND WE HAD IN A
MEETING I SHOULD BE BACK. OKAY.
OH, AND I HAVE SOME REMAIN. AS I
REMEMBER, MINH IS ON HIS WAY. HE
SAID, ONE MINUTE. OKAY AND HE
VOTED ON THE CONSENT CALENDAR.
DO YOU STILL WANT ME TO CALL FOR
MÀ IF YOU ALREADY VOTED ON IT?
OKAY. YEAH MAN, I ALL RIGHT, WE
WILL, OPEN IT BACK UP FROM
REESE'S. THAT IS OKAY. SO, SOME.
SORRY, SENATOR MINH, WE ARE
GOING TO GO AHEAD AND OPEN THE
ROLL, AND WE WILL. YOU'VE
ALREADY VOTED ON CONSENT, SO
WE'RE GOING TO START WITH FILE
ITEM ONE, BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CHEN AB 2618. OKAY. YEAH THAT
LET'S SEE. 11-3. OKAY. SO WE'RE
GOING TO GO WITH FILE ITEM FIVE
BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON AB
1934 ASSEMBLY BILL, 1934 MOTION
IS DUE. PASS THE SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR MINH MEN.
AYE. ALL RIGHT. NEXT WE WILL GO
TO FILE ITEM NUMBER SIX BY
MEMBER GRAYSON, AB 2017 ASSEMBLY
BILL, 2017 MOTION IS DUE. PASS
TO SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR
MINH MEN I SIX. ALL RIGHT. NEXT
WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM NUMBER
NINE BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAYSON
AB 2993. ASSEMBLY BILL 2993,
MOTION IS DUE. PASS AS AMENDED
TO SENATE JUDICIARY. SENATOR
MINH MEN I SIX. ALL RIGHT. AND
NEXT WE WILL GO TO FILE ITEM
NUMBER TEN. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
JONES SAWYER AB 3108. ASSEMBLY
BILL 3108. MOTION IS DUE. PASS
AS AMENDED TO SENATE PUBLIC
SAFETY. SENATOR MINH MINH I SIX.
ALL RIGHT. NEXT WE WILL GO TO
FILE ITEM 11 BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOH AB 3100. ASSEMBLY BILL 3100
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR MIN MIN I.
GREAT. PERFECT. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. WE ARE JUST MISSING ONE
MORE MEMBER, AND WE WILL NOT YOU
AND WE WILL GO AHEAD AND RECESS
UNTIL THAT MEMBER IS BACK.
WE ARE GOING TO OPEN UP THE
SENATE BANKING COMMITTEE HEARING
AGAIN. AND WE ARE ACTUALLY GOING
TO ADJOURN Þ AND Ó. SORRY, I DO
HAVE TO CLOSE THE ROLL ON EACH
ITEM ONE BY ONE. I THINK SO,
TIM, WE'VE GOT TO CLOSE THE ROLL
ONE BY ONE. YES. ALL RIGHT. SO
WE'RE GOING TO GO AHEAD AND GO
THROUGH THE ROLL ONE MORE TIME.
AND WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLL. SO
WE WILL START WITH CONSENT.
CONSENT CALENDAR. SENATOR
BRADFORD. SO CONSENT CALENDAR.
SENATOR BRADFORD F6. ALL RIGHT.
SO THAT THE CONSENT CALENDAR HAS
SIX VOTES AND WE WILL GO AHEAD
AND CLOSE THE ROLL. NEXT IS FILE
ITEM ONE. ASSEMBLY BILL 2618.
MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR BRADFORD
WE HAVE SIX. ALL RIGHT. SO THAT
WAS FILED ITEM ONE AB 2618. AND
THAT, IS SIX VOTES. AND WE WILL
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT. NEXT IS
FILE ITEM TWO. SORRY. NEXT IS
FILE ITEM THREE. ASSEMBLY BILL
3148. MOTION IS Dð PASSED TO
SENATE APPROPRIATIONS. SENATOR
BRADFORD, WE HAVE SIX. ALL
RIGHT. SO THAT HAS SIX VOTES.
WE'RE GOING TO CLOSE THE ROLL ON
THAT. NEXT WE HAVE FILE ITEM
FIVE. ASSEMBLY BILL 1934. MOTION
IS DUE. PASS TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR BRADFORD. ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS FIVE VOTES. AND
WE WILL CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT.
NEXT WE HAVE FILE ITEM NUMBER
SIX, ASSEMBLY BILL 2017. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR BRADFORD. ALL
RIGHT. THAT HAS SIX VOTES. WE
WILL GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THE ROLL
ON THAT. NEXT WE HAVE FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE AB 2993. ASSEMBLY
BILL 2993. MOTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR BRADFORD SIX. ALL RIGHT.
THAT HAS SIX VOTES. AND WE WILL
GO AHEAD AND CLOSE THE MOTION ON
THAT ASSEMBLY BILL. 3108 MOTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED TO SENATE
PUBLIC SAFETY. SENATOR BRADFORD,
WE HAVE SIX. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS
SIX VOTES. WE WILL CLOSE THE
ROLL ON THAT FILE. ITEM NUMBER
11, ASSEMBLY BILL 3100. MOTION
IS DUE PASSED TO SENATE
JUDICIARY. SENATOR BRADFORD HAS
SIX. ALL RIGHT. THAT HAS A SIX
VOTES. WE WILL GO AHEAD AND
CLOSE THE ROLL ON THAT. AND THE
FINAL ITEM IS ASSEMBLY BILL
2424. MOTION IS DO PASS AS
AMENDED TO SENATE JUDICIARY.
SENATOR BRADFORD ALL RIGHT. SO
THAT HAS SIX VOTES. WE WILL
CLOSE THE MOTION ON THAT. SO
WITH THAT WE WILL ADJOURN OUR
HEARING TODAY.